what's up man it's murda beast and check
me out on the bootleg kev podcast
all right man look we got a special
guest in here blue light kev show murder
beats
welcome man thank you for having me
legendary producer you know i would say
most producers have like eras right like
um growing up we had like
you know there was like the heat makers
and the dip set [ __ ] or timbaland and
you've had like a nice
eight nine year run now
uh i'd say about like five six years
like i've been making beats for ten
years so
well cause like like what the first migo
[ __ ] that you were a part of was 24 i
mean that was like eight years ago that
[ __ ] god damn yeah i mean we're kind of
in the murder beats decade here kind of
yeah man it's kind of crazy um well
welcome man uh
yeah i i feel like it's long overdue um
shout out to the uh the new record with
wale yes and blast
um
kind of like a different type of vibe
for you as far as like just what we're
used to hearing like a murder beats tag
on yeah um what was your inspiration
obviously you're out here in l.a so i'm
sure i mean you hear blast every [ __ ]
way yeah i do i'm a fan of blast you
know what i'm saying um so i was
actually six months ago i was in miami
working with rick ross we were at circle
house you know i'm sorry i love circle
house yeah so i was cooking up some [ __ ]
kind of the the beat the record kind of
sounds like a miami tropical it does
kind of sound like a feel-good record so
um someone was like yo you want me blast
i was like yeah bring him in the studio
he came in the studio
and i met him i like pulled up that beat
he banged it out quick i was like this
[ __ ] fire and then um wale was in the
other room i went grab wall a he wrote
his verse did it quick and then i was
like man i'm taking this one wow all in
miami yeah wow crazy like one day shout
out to circle house for people who don't
know it's like a house in a neighborhood
in miami yeah shout
that's like a
renowned studio that you would never
even know was there if you just never
know
normal ass like
it's just a crit it's like a really nice
house with studios in it yeah it's
really just like a normal crib in like a
normal neighborhood and you know yeah
100 how did you okay so like you kind of
obviously got introduced in the game at
least from my understanding when i first
started hearing you was through the
migos
what was your initial introduction with
them being a kid from canada being that
at that time
the migos were active out here because i
lived in tampa when the migos started to
pop and them dudes was they was really
oh they were really out here mad shows
had their mcm bags on [ __ ] shootouts
and [ __ ] all kinds of crazy [ __ ] was
popping off but how did this
how did those two worlds connect um so i
just connected with them on twitter like
that i was hitting up everyone on
twitter facebook youtube i was just
hitting people up so i just like hit up
one of their boys i was like yo
play play some of the play some of my
beats for them and i'm going to give you
some beats to wrap on at the time this
guy wasn't even rapping he was like i'm
actually engineering them so send the
pack i sent the pack and then from there
you know what i'm saying that easy yeah
it's crazy because
nowadays
way harder to do that think about like
dm in someone like no one's going to
check your dm it's crazy that's why like
people always ask me for advice and
stuff i'm like i don't even know what
kind of advice to give somebody because
what worked for me it's going to be hard
to work for someone else
back in the day like there wasn't a lot
of people trying to be a producer it
wasn't cool to be in music it was very
like unrealistic so everyone kind of
like stayed away from it
so like but like with the internet and
how the internet was working and stuff i
used that to my advantage because like i
was just a kid from canada i'm from a
town of 30 000 people like what part of
canada are you from like i'm from like
niagara region so it's like niagara
falls yeah just outside of niagara falls
why you're a buffalo fan you know what
i'm saying there we go so like i was
like i grew up on the border of buffalo
in a small town 30 000 people
so we i've been to buffalo it's a pretty
[ __ ]
wild place it is pretty wild i'm not
gonna lie it's very like when i went
there and like hung out with conway and
uh and west side gun and i was like i
get it now i get why you guys are real
[ __ ] rap about the [ __ ] you rap about
cause that [ __ ] look like it's like the
it's the poorest part of america i was
gonna say when i think of cleveland in
my head
and then i went to buffalo i've never
been to cleveland but i was like this is
what i'm when i think of cleveland i
think of this but it's buffalo so when i
first started going to chicago i was
like and we were in the wild 100s the
south side all like these crazy places
you'd be hearing about i'm like this
[ __ ] looks just like buffalo yeah both
was crazy so i went back to buffalo like
damn like you know but funny story about
conway in them i was like i used to go
to buffalo first trying to like go to
america get my get my producer [ __ ] off
you know what i'm saying i used to go
pull up on them and i pulled up on
conway in the studio one day and this
boy tried to buy my drums on me for like
50 bucks i remember just just like a
like your f file of drums like i was
just playing beasts like man your drums
are hard man can't buy him yeah he's
like can i buy him like i'm like [ __ ]
how much he's like 50 bucks i'm like no
not even like 250. he's like 175 or
something i was like nah was it
derringer
no i think it was uh dj shea r.i.p oh
shout out to dj shea rest in peace man
shay's a legend for sure it was crazy yo
that's wild did you ever end up
having any records with conway or benny
or any of those guys yeah i did i did a
record on kanye on conway's last album
oh you did that's right anza yeah yeah
yeah so and that was just cause like i'm
like man we gotta do some [ __ ] we still
gotta do more [ __ ] like jeff vinny all
these guys just for the region got to do
some [ __ ] it's so crazy too because
being on the canada side of that um
border
it's a lot easier for you to go back and
forth i i got people who are like you
know some of some of the homies who are
part of bsf or or gorzella they're like
man we've lived in buffalo our whole
life so we can't even go to [ __ ]
canada we've never even been into canada
yeah that's probably because they you
know they got felonies yeah the same
thing with me though it's like if i got
a dui i wouldn't be able to come to
america really yeah if i had a
misdemeanor i wouldn't be able to come
to america like did you go to like did
you grow up going to buffalo a lot to go
to games man people people people from
canada go to buffalo to get fill up
their tank of gas because gas is cheaper
go to the store to get groceries because
y'all got way more [ __ ] brands and
everything like so like it's like when
you live on a border town people go to
buffalo or america all the time that's
like here like border towns like people
go to mexico to get medicine tijuana or
some [ __ ] well look at him yeah because
medicine you don't need a prescription
to get like a z pack out here you need a
prescription for everything you just go
over to mexico and just get
viagra for like twenty dollars
yeah there's people everyone's [ __ ]
teeth all these rappers with their teeth
they're usually going to mexico to get
them things done yeah i've been i've
only been to mexico one time
i went uh
i dj'd a new year's party in cancun like
last year during covent did you enjoy it
it was pretty lit but it was like during
like the crazy peak of cove and it was
like everyone was like i don't know if
we should go i don't know if we should
be doing this it might be a bad look you
might get shamed yeah you know what i'm
saying but it was fun are you um do you
go back home a lot uh a little bit i
haven't been in like two years since
colbert we're about to say it's probably
a i mean
because they pretty much shut the [ __ ]
down over there yeah it was shutting
down opening up shutting down raptors
had to play in tampa last year that was
crazy like what the [ __ ] is going on i
wanted to go to some games i never did
that i wish they would have did limited
edition like tampa bay raptors jerseys
that'd be hard that would've been hard
dropped as an nft you know yeah that
would've been crazy shout out to the
raptors um
so let's talk about uh your tag because
you have one of the more iconic tags in
hip-hop
uh and i always say you know i had a
conversation with hit boy and hippo was
saying for the longest time he didn't
have a tag and it kind of hurt him
because you know we think of like hit
boy as like one of the more legendary
producers of all time but some of his
biggest fans
don't have his name on him you know so
he started using a tag your tag is very
iconic at this point um how did you find
your tag what like like kind of break
down the story of how you got your tag
so the the murder on the beatso is not
nice tag um me and baka shout out to
baka yeah shout out to baka we were um
we were like recording in toronto and
then like he just said that on the track
and i was like i should kind of use that
then one day sunny digital was in
toronto and i was like yo like should i
use this as a tag and i play the song
he's like you should you should try it
out and then
i started using it and then drake told
me to put it on everything from there on
and that's how it came about and now
it's like but like
my old mama murder tag i got that [ __ ]
like i like bought it off some guy on
the internet for like 20 bucks he like
made it for me and i wanted that because
i was on mixtapes and [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying so
when you're listening to a mixtape no
label two some some old kind of mixtape
you listen you hear my tag you'd see
produced by merton that's what was
driving like beat sales people would hit
me up on twitter
whatever like yo it's like an
advertising i'm saying that was how i
was getting money so i was trying to
like promote myself and build my brand
you know no you've done a good job at
that um
when you first started to kind of like i
always feel like with producers now
there's so many different
avenues for you to be
like support yourself as a producer
because we always think like the
placement game is like such a
a tough game if you're an up-and-coming
producer
like chasing placements going in the
studio trying to get your beats in the
right people it's hard especially now
too man because now it's like when i was
coming up there was probably like
500 producers thousand producers trying
to do it on the internet now there's
like 10 million it's wild 50 million
literally like 50 million kids
so it's like if you're trying to chase a
placement on an album and you get that
album cut on a big artist like how are
you supposed to even build a brand off
that right you know like i feel like the
biggest way for a producer to
build nowadays is
to
build come up with an artist and build a
sound you know what i mean yeah like
find an artist that you [ __ ] with
do the whole album
then they blow up and then you know what
i'm saying that i feel like that's like
the best way to build a brand yeah
because you build a sound you know what
i mean i think the uh what's the one
kid's name uh
logic's producer him like logic's
producer did like all of his [ __ ] and
like obviously that dude's got a grammy
and all that [ __ ] but yeah and then you
and then you're like associated with an
act and like that [ __ ] goes a long way
you know what i'm saying yeah i mean you
kind of like in a way kind of did that
with amigos early on yeah you know you
were kind of synonymous with like what
they were doing because the thing is
with them is like back then like they
were only [ __ ] with like three four
producers and i was one of them or like
three to five they had like a few you
know what i mean but like they were not
[ __ ] with anyone else's beats and
like no one can get a hold of them so
like you know what i mean just being a
part of that was like very exclusive and
like everybody wanted my beats what was
it like being like around them in
atlanta in like the early years because
it had to be crazy right yeah it was fun
though because they're running atl at
the time they're running the streets
yeah they were doing shows shutting
clubs down going crazy we used to have
fun at the crib it was fun what was the
first um
kind of hit that really popped in the
club for you that you did for them was
it pipe it up emma smith emmett smith
that [ __ ] was crazy i remember going on
the road with them and like seeing it on
like bet like on the tv about the first
time i ever heard my tag on the tv i was
like damn this is crazy that's gotta be
wise i had like no money everyone back
home thought i was like rich like
everyone aliens of course it was like
this [ __ ] was crazy man but emma smith
you know what i'm saying that was like
the first time i even seen people dab in
a music video that was like when they
dab that they were like oh that was the
touchdown
yeah and then pipe it up really blew up
the deck that was crazy crazy pipe it up
was a moment that was my first hit
though piping up was like a hit i
remember like playing that [ __ ] in
florida radio going crazy oh my god pipe
it up was one of them once i got my
first like 20 000 check off that song
wow
and i was like we were like we made it
that's a nice chunk of change yeah you
know what i'm saying um but we're
talking about producers like kind of
monetizing their [ __ ] now you know
there's uh people who still do beat
leases and then there's like obviously
like
i feel like one of the most like slept
on ways that people find beats and i
know this because we'll have artists
come in
and they'll be like yo yo here's the
youtube link it's like these tight beats
on youtube hell yeah every a lot of
upcoming artists and a lot of like
made artists they'll be doing that go
and they'll type in their own name type
beat make a bunch of songs you know that
[ __ ] happens a lot we've had so many
artists come in be like yo i want to do
a freestyle over this but it's uh
there's some beat on youtube and it'll
be like their own name type beat they'll
be like what the [ __ ] do you even know
this guy they're like nah nah we just
[ __ ] with the beat on youtube i'm like
yeah that's how i started i used to do
type beats every producer's type b on
youtube walk a flock of type b slim
dunkin type beats all these type beats
and i used to like drive traction like
when cheeky was hot i do cheap keef type
beat i had a beat i remember how to be
it was like 250 000 views and [ __ ] like
that's a lot on a b hell yeah you know
so you were kind of like already kind of
doing your thing a little bit
in the producer space yeah like i
remember like there was like the
internet producers and [ __ ] yeah like we
were doing our thing and then i started
like showing like what i looked like and
[ __ ] and i was like oh [ __ ] like who's
this nobody ever would have thought you
looked this way yeah and then like i
feel like that was more like a wow
factor like damn what the [ __ ] he's from
canada like everyone else kind of just
had like their graphic up on their on
their twitter and [ __ ] i was like man i
want to build my face card i want people
to know what i look like you know who
was um with all the people you've worked
with you've worked with everyone drake
travis we can go on nicky et cetera
um as far as like in studio experience
whose creative process is like the most
meticulous
where you're just like yo this this is
like different because i always hear
like guys like dr dre's creative process
is insane like he's so particular about
like the smallest [ __ ] and i've been in
sessions with artists that like care
about
[ __ ] that you wouldn't even like think
of like who's that artist that you've
been in with that just very over the top
with just caring about the small details
them
um
hmm probably just like i don't know i
feel like a lot of artists do but um
definitely like the atlanta artists like
cuevo the migos
um thug future i feel like guys that
just freestyle everything they do but
then like they're also like so like
aware of like how they're saying it like
their tone and like their vocals and
[ __ ] like that's pretty crazy you know
what i'm saying i have this thing that i
always say about producers like i mean
uh artists and [ __ ] like it's like if
they get it or they don't get it and
like it's like
i feel like
how like party could like go and just
freestyle whole song and it's like
incredible or like juice world could
like freestyle whole beating it would be
like an incredible song y w melee the
same it's like certain artists just got
it like you know what i'm saying like
like you could just pull up a b for
juice rp or like melee parties and they
would just go and just they could
literally freestyle the whole beat and
it's like a finished song that shit's
crazy that's incredible isn't it
different like when you're in with a
producer that does that that does the
punch in thing or does the off the top
thing as opposed to somebody who writes
[ __ ] i don't even know who writes [ __ ]
down anymore because it feels like most
people just go in and they do they they
do the melody or they they do the
punching thing or they punch in line by
line like is there like a big difference
for you like being in the studio who
actually writes 100 so like it was like
a gift and a curse with amigos because i
was like so young i was like 19 20 years
old working with these guys they're
freestyling everything punching in and
stuff and then when i started working
with other people and people were
writing i like didn't have patience in
the studio for it because it's like it's
a much more patience like driven process
yeah like i could go i could go in with
amigos they could pull up a beat half of
the song done in 20 minutes i was
cooking up beats in like 30 minutes 20
minutes i was like our workflow was so
quick but our chemistry was crazy you
know what i'm saying so it's like then
going in with someone who has to sit
there and write some people write for an
hour some people aren't as quick with it
you know what i'm saying it's not a bad
thing everyone's creative it's just a
different process i'll just be like man
what the [ __ ] are we doing let's move on
to the next record yeah you know he's
like i'm gonna go to dave's hot chicken
and come back let me know when you're
ready hey shut up daiso chicken hey what
up we gotta stop the podcast real quick
shout out to my bookie man listen if you
know anything about me you know i like
to gamble on sports and i've been using
my bookie for so long go to mybookie.ag
check it out they're doing the my bookie
double deposit bonus this is how this
works
you sign up you make a deposit you use
the promo code bootleg
and you're gonna get double your money
they're gonna match your deposit up to a
thousand dollars there's so much action
right now too the nba season is going
crazy maybe you could do a future right
who do you think is going to win the mvp
i don't know is it going to be honest is
it going to be devin booker is it going
to be
jokic certainly ain't gonna be
[ __ ] russell westbrook
crazy odds that ain't gonna happen
that's just burning money with that
being said there's so many different
ways you can bet you can bet on your
daily games you can do the parlay i like
doing money line parlays i like to just
do three or four heavy favorites on that
nba schedule throw them all on one
ticket and and just try to hit you know
what i'm saying whatever you're into my
bookie you can bet on it anything go to
mybookie.ag they got the double deposit
bonus right now this is important sign
up for an account make a deposit and
they will match your deposit double your
money up to a thousand dollars right now
that's free money so what are you doing
use the promo code bootleg when you sign
up and you can double your money get in
on some of this nba action man it's nba
season all-star games this weekend so
much to i mean you could bet on the
three-point contest the [ __ ]
dunk contest whatever the [ __ ] is going
on who's gonna be the mvp of the
all-star game i don't know but you could
bet on it you could bet on anything so
make sure one more time that's my bookie
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars using that promo code
bootleg place your bets what are we
doing bet on anything anytime anywhere
with my booking [ __ ] let's go um
a lot of a lot of people get to your
position right like obviously you came
up making beats but then there's i i
know a lot of producers who end up
getting to a certain point um
where they start kind of surrounding
themselves with other producers to kind
of just help with the creative process
whether it's loops whether it's
you know whatever it is a lot more
co-production starts to happen is that a
space you're in are you still very much
hands-on with everything you're doing um
i definitely started like doing a lot of
collaborating probably like 2016. you
know i'm saying i feel like
music is a collaborative sport you know
what i mean so it's just like when you
have a band and you're making the songs
you play guitar i play drums you play
bass he sings then like sometimes the
drummer would help write the lyrics it's
like it's a collaborative effort you
know what i'm saying so i feel like
collaborating in music is very important
because we all just trying to make the
best [ __ ] you know i'm saying it don't
matter if i make it by myself and then
you know what i'm saying if if any
problem
and you make the better work
you're the smarter guy we got to work
smart not hard you know what i'm saying
but um yeah man i don't know still
though it's like
i definitely surround myself sometimes a
lot of producers but i still just like i
like workflow just like being by myself
pulling [ __ ] up maybe like talking
people on facetime this that like i like
to get in with people you know but then
i just get distracted i feel like what
are your well like your creative process
with beats is it fruity loops is it pro
tools is it logic what do you what are
you yeah fl 11 free loops 11. so you'll
still be just cooking up on the laptop
and your headphones cooking up
speakers on the kitchen table cooking up
like just having fun with it you know
that's amazing just trying to like stay
inspired and stuff you know what i'm
saying because i feel like where i'm at
in my career it's not all about just
like making 30 beats a day like i used
to you know i got a lot more like
djing brandon stuff trying to draw my
own singles it's like a lot more to it
than just like making beats every day
you know you and uh shorty shorty did a
very slept on collab project shout out
to shorty shorty shout out shorty um my
boy what what like you know when it
comes to someone like shorty shorty who
obviously
um
to me is like one of the more slept on
guys in the game i feel like uh maybe
it's because he's from baltimore i don't
know what it is but he got bangers um
but what what inspired you to want to do
like a project with someone like him um
just because like i feel like he was
slept on and he's so talented you know
what i'm saying i've been a fan of him
for years so i just like finally hit him
upside he was in la we locked in i think
the first studio session we made good
evening mm-hmm i just thought that was
such like a cool different record where
i was like man let's shoot this video in
malibu in two days i'm like let's just
bang on the album we banged out the
album in like probably like two weeks
that's so crazy is there anybody else
you would want to do a collab project
with at this point um
definitely some people like so maybe
someone who's kind of in that same space
where you feel like they might be a
little slept on like yeah no you might
be able to shine some light on what
they're doing if you collab 100
um probably like no cap i think no no
i think you just got a plaque too for
vaccine shout out to you yes i don't
know cat i think he's super talented got
the craziest bars no he's crazy and i
hear he freestyles everything too too
yeah
it's just crazy though cause i like
listening to his music and then like
every time i listen to his [ __ ] i'm like
listening and dissecting a new bar like
damn that [ __ ] is crazy the way you flip
that you know no he's crazy for sure um
you obviously working with nikki has got
to be i mean she's
one of the greatest of all time yeah
she's super talented um nicki yeah shout
out to nikki how weird was it being like
uh
you know with all the six nine [ __ ]
happening obviously
you you you're a white kid from [ __ ]
the niagara region so like whether or
not the dude's a snitch or not probably
doesn't matter to you
but did that kind of like uh because i
feel like that was his biggest record at
least that to me was the fifi is one of
my biggest records i think about to be
diamond well fifi's like the only record
i feel like he ever dropped that like
was like i really had real crossover
like potent i was like yo this [ __ ] is
like undeniable at that point but like
what was that i think it was just
perfect timing great timing on on his
behalf coming off nice for what he was
super hot nicky obviously you know what
i'm saying that's just a knockout what
was like the story behind how that came
together was the nikki have a lot to do
with it or was it six nine thing first
like
um i pulled up on him we made the record
in new york
and then we were like just like
brainstorming who we should get on it he
really wanted to get nicki on it he got
nikki on and then yeah it was over
because was this prior after you did no
frauds
i didn't know fraud's like 2017 20 2017.
this was like
we did the fifi record probably like
2018 2018
2018 yeah
shout out no fraud is a bang or two no
frauds was so hard that was a banger
though
i remember like drake called me he was
like yo
he sent me the record and i was like
damn this supposed to be crazy i got one
with nikki drake and wayne i was like
and it was like a statement record for
yeah i was like yeah it was like a
little because that was what she was
going through the remy my [ __ ] i was
like i remember i remember playing that
and like and like my parents i was like
upstairs i'm like damn this [ __ ] crazy
that's [ __ ] wild now that you're
doing like live gigs right like um
it's a whole different game it is a
whole different game people don't
realize that [ __ ] i love djing now man
like were you ever djing in the past no
so i wasn't djing and like
people were telling me to start djing
because people want to start seeing me
so we were getting booking offers and
[ __ ] i was like man i don't really want
a dj right and then we finally we took
one like five years ago it was like a
new year's gig in um hawaii
i was like teaching myself how to dj in
like the [ __ ] hotel room before sound
checking oh wow i was like learning in
soundcheck i'd like to brought someone
with me and like yeah like from then
even like i didn't really [ __ ] with dj
but then like when i started going on
tours and [ __ ] like i tried to have a
good time and then like coachella like i
brought out like dmx and ferg where's
the kid ty and like that [ __ ] was just
like so incredible i just started like
to like the feeling you know what i'm
saying and like controlling the energy
and like you know what i'm saying you
could play certain records get the crowd
going and you're like you could play
just a lot of your own [ __ ] like that
yeah that's
like like when i when i when i play in
like so like my birthday's friday mm-hmm
um i'm performing at hakkasan on my
birthday oh it's about to be super dope
i might as well dj yeah wine party on my
birthday you know what i'm saying
because i'm gonna party either way so
it's like when i'm djing in vegas i play
for like two hours you know what i'm
saying it's a long time so i'll play
some of my records and stuff but i just
really want to just like play what i
think everyone's going to go crazy too
you know like i'm just trying to curate
like a crazy party
for sure yeah like you want to play your
own [ __ ] but like you also want to make
sure you like you don't want to be the
guy that only plays your disguise or
[ __ ] like you know what i'm saying like
i just like you and everyone yeah yeah
you want everyone halfway
you know i love the party man like i
love to turn up and have fun so like i
just feel like when i'm djing i'm like
i'm on the auction you know what i'm
saying you gotta rewind a little bit
when you did coachella i didn't know you
brought dmx out crazy
well how'd that happen that's a wild um
generational difference there we were
trying to figure out who to bring out
and i think it was my manager's id he
was like man we should bring out dmx i
heard he's like in the bay so we ended
up like booking him a sprinter from like
the bay to coachella oh wow and like he
made it like just on time like like he
made it like just not like we didn't
even know if he was gonna make it though
like that whole time i coachell like i
didn't know if rich i didn't know if
certain people were even gonna pull out
i kept looking back like are they just
dmx here
yeah but uh he came out on stage you
know i'm saying he did his thing too
that was crazy now i was like i feel
like that was like the first
like big performance back that he had
because i know after that he did some
rolling rounds and you know what i'm
saying but i was like that was a big one
man
rpx man it's crazy you mentioned your
birthday because uh i used to work with
a weed company in arizona called vapin
and they sponsored your birthday party
yeah it's my guy ty owns the company
yeah 2018 so i was there and are you
were you in arizona no uh i mean yeah i
mean i'm from arizona but they threw a
crazy party in arizona oh the house
party tray sinatra was dj
pilo was there that [ __ ] was lit i
canceled my
yg was three hours late to our interview
out here in la
so i was either going to stay in l.a and
interview yg
and miss my flight to go dj that [ __ ]
party
and i ended up doing the yg interview
yes and then dre sinatra covered for me
and dj that [ __ ] i was on tour with uh
g-eazy tai
the white boozy uzi yeah
yeah that [ __ ] was mad fun man they took
us to the the the uh the weed warehouse
and [ __ ] saw like so much [ __ ] weed
no but they sponsored your birthday out
here i think yeah by that time i was
working with them and like uh yeah that
was a lip party there was a wild uh that
that was when i first met the elk boys
they had just moved from canada to here
uh mellie was there
kodak was there they were lit that was
that was actually crazy that melly and
kodak were both there at the same time
yeah that [ __ ] was man that was right
before
i want to say that was right before
mellie got locked up
because we where the last interview did
he did and i think we interviewed him
like the day or two before that and then
i feel like he got locked up like
a week after that or something yeah no
he definitely
he wanted to come turn up real quick you
know yeah yeah that was a pretty epic
yeah you know how to party for sure
free my boy melly man you know what i'm
saying
i don't know what's going on with that i
just know every every two weeks there's
like an update and some of them
sometimes are contradicting and i'm like
i don't know what the [ __ ] gonna
happen you you and you and melly like
talk about that relationship like he's
obviously a very uh
i wouldn't say misunderstood but very
man he's a talented he's like an enigma
super talented artist man like i just
like started listening to his music i'm
like man this kid's fire
um ended up finding some time when he
was in la pulled up on him we did like
five records i'd say four or five
records
um and like he was kind of like the same
thing like freestyling everything going
crazy i was like man this kid's talented
[ __ ] like super talented you know what i
mean and then he ended up getting locked
up and [ __ ] so
uh i released one record i had the
banana split record i had that i put
dirk on it dropped that like during
covin
and then he dropped a couple records and
i think there's like one or two more
records we got in the vault that are
that are probably coming out soon so
stay tuned do you still um like tap in
with up and coming producers for like
loops or [ __ ] like that like someone has
like a fire loop pack like would you
still like
tap in with some 100 man 100 man my
email is [ __ ] crazy i feel i swear
these kids are selling my email i swear
they're selling my email or something
because there's always just some
upcoming kids producers sending me [ __ ]
and i always just [ __ ] with them like
i'm like man might as well you know what
i'm saying like just like when i was a
young kid it's like boy wonder you know
what i'm saying i have one up and then
one is like yeah pull up on me i go pull
up this crib cook up it's like the same
thing you know what i'm saying the youth
man music's a young sport it is man so
it's like you know what i'm saying these
kids are amazing at making beats now
like i'm like damn they making
my [ __ ] sound kind of you know what i'm
saying like i gotta figure out how to
make my [ __ ] more special because these
kids are 13 years old making the hardest
[ __ ] what is like uh the secret to your
run being as long as it's been and
continuing because there are as like i
said there are people who have errors
but there are a lot of producers that
will have like a two year spike and then
they just go away
that's happened a lot like what do you
think has kind of been the secret to
your sauce for longevity just being
grateful
um
god you know what i mean and just like
building a sustainable brand
that's like here to last you know what
i'm saying like it's not like i like i
just think i had i had my little rumble
like i'm still like pumping [ __ ] out you
know what i'm saying so just gotta stay
grateful stay down keep working stay
focused you know but um and i think a
lot of it's just timing you know like
coming out of like i started to like get
build my brand during the end of the
mixtape era and that and then i have my
running like the very beginning of
streaming streaming yeah for sure you
know what i mean yeah two different
errors for sure it was like the dap era
all the way up to the stream i was
always on live mixtapes
soundcloud all that [ __ ] soundcloud you
know what i mean i still use the dapp
app for certain [ __ ] i can't get on the
dsps it's like the only place i can
listen to it
and like i even caught like the
soundcloud era like when it was like at
his peak too like even butterfly effect
like i remember that was straight to
soundcloud travis dropped a three pack i
remember he dropped off three i'm like
damn i don't know these other songs are
fired too the next day butterfly effect
had like 14 million plays on sp on uh
soundcloud in one day and they were like
yo this single push like it was just
like from there pushed it un unmixed
straight to radio everything i remember
i remember when that happened that
record was like crazy i've never seen
some [ __ ] like i think out of my whole
career like that record like the first
day was like the craziest [ __ ] like yeah
and it still researches really well
because we still play the [ __ ] out of it
in l.a on the radio like yeah that song
that song was awesome
and the thing is too with that record i
feel like it didn't do as good
on radio or like the chart wise well as
it should because it was such like a
cultural song for like shows and like
live performance you know what i mean
hey we gotta stop the podcast man real
quick appreciate y'all for watching uh
really mean mean it subscribe like leave
a comment even if you're one of those
[ __ ] who leaves a comment yo why
you always interrupting the guests
because it's my [ __ ] podcast i don't
know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
chi chi chong what are you into the odd
socks basics are the boys though that's
my favorite you know you get yourself a
nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20
off if you go to oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev
all together
at checkout 20 off oddssoxofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
you know i um i think of like uh certain
producers beats like uh when we think of
like just blaze like exhibit c is like
his like magnum opus like like what's
your in your opinion your favorite or
your best beat that you've ever made
that like not the biggest but just the
one beat that you're like this [ __ ] is
so crazy if you take the rappers off
this [ __ ] is just a banger
buzzing
by party next door and lil yachty i feel
like that beat is just crazy the bounce
and everything about that beat is so
different it's just so hard but if we're
talking like big beats too like i think
motorsport man that beat just smacks
like i don't know what i did i think i
had the kick way too loud and then they
when they mixed it but that [ __ ] knocks
in the club yeah motorsport uh was a
crazy moment only time we've heard nikki
and carty on a record together crazy
when you when you did that record did
the migos like did you have any idea
that that was going to be the plan to
like put them to on the on the song or
even
um nah so
i made the beat in toronto i made that
[ __ ] on like a little ass speaker man
like this big and my boy's condo i sent
it to a couple artists then i ended up
pulling up on the migos in um new york
at quad and i pulled up that beat and we
me and cuevo made motorsport right there
and then i think like a couple months
later he told me like he's like yeah i
got cardi and they can't like man you're
crazy man
you know what i'm saying
but out of anybody that could have did
that he did it you know what i'm saying
he did do it he did that [ __ ] that
probably never is going to happen again
that [ __ ] was crazy that was a that was
a moment yeah real [ __ ] that was a
[ __ ] moment for sure what is um like
now that you obviously are working on
your new album are you going to be uh
are we just doing singles are we doing a
project
uh i'm definitely trying to gear up for
a project but i definitely want to keep
just dropping singles and i definitely
want to like showcase like new talent
too you know what i'm saying because i
dropped one project ever
it was um in 2016 i dropped keep god
first it was a mixtape and like i had
like a lot of people on there before
they were really big like like i had
like solo offset songs on there before
baton bougie i had like played with
cardi on there before he he really
popped off like everyone was kind of
like you know what i'm saying had some
people from kids from toronto on there
before they popped off so i feel like
it's important
as a producer to drop a project and like
put people on like give them you're
using your platform you know what i'm
saying so with this with the new music
you want to make sure you're also i mean
you did that with shorty shorty i feel
like because i feel like shorty shorty i
mean obviously bachelor was a golden
platinum record yeah he was already
doing his thing i still feel like he
kind of
you know it was it was it was dope to
see him collaborate with you because i
knew it would bring new eyes to what he
does yeah and i feel like it worked out
perfect so you know who are some of the
new artists that you're like really
you know because you got a great ear
that you're really [ __ ] with that
like you know you you kind of feel like
you're in a similar space to you were in
2016 to kind of put them on um or help
at least there's this kid duvi in
toronto super fire
he's like he's probably next up in
canada shout out to doovey he's dope um
definitely like no cap you know i'm
saying i [ __ ] with him there's there's
like so many people you know what i'm
saying so he's got to see who who i work
with what i appreciate about you is that
at least not to my knowledge
you haven't done the low hanging fruit
edm [ __ ] yet what is that just edm like
like a murder beats like [ __ ] fist
pump vegas anthem that like
like i feel like
you know you know what i mean right like
because now that you're dj and i'm sure
it's like you you might get the edge to
be like man i need one of these
because you know all the edm feel it
because all the edm djs are stealing
from hip hop [ __ ] all the edm guys are
making rap records i [ __ ] with a lot of
the dj's though you know what i'm saying
shout out to all the dj's they're all
cool but they're still they're still all
making rap records it's just hard for me
because like i'm like a hip-hop dj so
it's like i'm not even playing like edm
and [ __ ] on my shows
do you feel some type of way when you
see some of these edm guys like making
rap records you're like well you're just
kind of like this is not what you do
like not really i don't know it is what
it is music is music at the end of the
day that's fair you know it only matters
who does it better right that is true
that is true whoever does it better
pretty much and hey i will give i'll
give i got to get props to skrillex
cause skrillex is a [ __ ] beast of a
producer he is a beast of a producer
i've been in the studio with him a
couple times he's a monster yeah he'd be
playing guitar a bunch of [ __ ] he could
do all kinds of [ __ ] um
what about like uh placement-wise like
do you got any big records coming
i got some [ __ ] going some [ __ ] coming i
i'm not gonna lie my next single i'm
really excited about i'm about to drop
some [ __ ] when is that coming some [ __ ]
uh probably soon
how many artists are on there with you
uh
three can i try to guess
uh
if i guess correctly will you confirm
um
i don't i don't know you can guess
though i don't know give me one city
from one of the artists ah
earth earth come on man
i don't know
obviously atlanta maybe yeah it could be
yeah
this guy said could be
i'm gonna let you break it though have
you um it'll be crazy have you ever
worked with kanye
uh we worked on i work with kanye on
some of the six nine [ __ ] like oh when
he was doing this
and what uh what was that the six nine
records he put out never really i'm
trying to remember something yeah the
songs uh i did both of them the kanga
one kango yeah yeah yeah uh the mama one
or some [ __ ]
would you work with six nine again
i don't know no i don't know probably
not huh it's gotta make sense right yeah
i don't know it's gotta you know what
i'm saying i mean him an nba young boy
apparently got a [ __ ] five records
together which is that's probably pretty
crazy i don't know you know what i'm
saying it's lit what about young boy
would you work with young boys i already
do work with young boys like what's
what's his his thing man cause i feel
like he's i feel like he's a super
talented he's super talented but i just
feel like he might be a little
misunderstood
he's very like uh
he's just kind of on an island yeah in
hip-hop he's he's dope though he's a
dope artist you know what i'm saying no
one can take that from oh 100 no he's
incredible i just feel like you know
he's just like i've never seen someone
just on an island and they just don't
give a [ __ ] about anything else in his
own world kind of doing his own thing
it's pretty wild yeah but it's working
for him too it is working it is working
uh any new migo [ __ ] coming that you're
a part of
it's coming it's coming amigos are
always working you know i love the the
the last migos album was super crazy
yeah i'm happy they got somehow slept on
as well i don't think the new migos
album that came out last year had as
much love as it should have because it
was [ __ ] amazing i feel like it just
took a long time to get it out but
finally it came out and like i feel like
it did what it did you know what i'm
saying like they had this [ __ ] on there
i feel like everyone who listened to it
was like it was a solid album you know
and that's what you might have at the
end of the day well the song is going
crazy uh one shot with uh shout out to
wale shout out to blast are you gonna be
tapping with any other la guys um
100
because blast is the is obviously the
hottest right but there's so much talent
in l.a there's a lot of town in l.a i
feel like la's kind of like toronto in a
way where there's like a lot of
underground so much artists you know
what i'm saying and they just got to
figure out how to like any la guys who
you kind of got your eye on that you're
just [ __ ] with their music as like a
awesome fan [ __ ] um
there's a couple i don't i don't know
i don't know yeah this song there's some
yeah okay well there it is man well
listen uh the song is crazy
looking forward to
more singles this year yes sir the next
singles coming soon with three artists
from earth
be on the lookout for those uh
are you i mean are you dabbling into the
nft [ __ ] at all hell yeah man you know
what i'm saying the wallet is looking
crazy what a like uh
i i'm fully tapped in with like
cryptocurrency and i have my own crypto
[ __ ] going that's good man the nft world
i still haven't touched because i'm
afraid like i just feel like there's so
much [ __ ] going on no for sure like
a lot of his rug pulls um nine one
percent of it is like will last so just
like make sure you when you say rug pool
what does that mean it's just like a lot
of it just people are just trying to
make money you know quick nuts yeah yeah
rug pool yeah pull them around now they
got your money the [ __ ] out of here yeah
but you've been pretty heavy in the
crypto for a while i've been i've been
having the crypto for like the last
couple years so when bitcoin was at like
9 000.
well [ __ ] even though it took a [ __ ] now
it's still it's gonna go right back up
did you buy do you buy more when the dip
happens yes i buy the div not every dip
because it's like this is a pretty big
[ __ ] dip that just happened yeah like
it was funny so like it was dipping and
like i bought some and then it kept
going [ __ ] i'm like what so i do i buy
more now but now it's going back up so
yeah it's always like when the dip
happens you always don't know when you
see the floor is hit the thing is is
like once you start to pay attention to
the crypto and you you kind of like you
can kind of like understand like what's
happening in in the market you know what
i'm saying like you can kind of be like
all right cool like once you hit a dip
everyone's like freaking out selling did
you buy dogecoin i did buy those kind of
lost some money on those coins
[ __ ] those man
what's been like the your best alt coin
that you've invested in that you made
some money on
uh
[ __ ] the alt coins man um i don't know
i'm just like heavy in the crypt uh
bitcoin ethereum ethereum's the one i
think ethereum is the one because
everyone's using ethereum nfts and
i feel like ethereum at least like
prac practicability like like people
actually use it in the meta universe
like it feels like the currency people
buy stuff with yeah no for sure and you
know what i'm saying i know that like
in the future like yeah people are going
to be using like you're going to be
using bitcoin to buy things in stores
and should i saw like microsoft's going
to be using ethereum in a couple years
so like when you're online it's like
it's just gonna get crazy man i just
want people to get hip and like educate
like you know people like to hate on
what they don't understand and i feel
that's a problem in the world and in
society people just have to educate
learn you go on youtube watch a
two-minute video on crypto and learn a
little bit and i feel like if once you
buy something you just start to
understand it it's like addicting it's
like fun you know what i mean no crypto
it's cool it's like a fun i mean like
look and plus there's i made some great
money off of ripple shout out to ripple
that xrp and then it's like it's a whole
different community you can get involved
in and then there's parties for those
communities i heard the parties are
crazy have you been booked at any of
those parties
they're lit man that's money fun people
everybody just wants to make money with
you or make you some money and they're
trying to get you to start your own
murder beats coin oh they're trying to
start everything
metaverse everything yeah like like have
you rolled out your own because you know
i've seen uh
i'm trying to think of the producer uh
ill mind be doing nft [ __ ] shut up man
he'd be he'd be doing his thing don't
mind he's like hustler he's getting
money the thing about ill mind is like
he's at the forefront of like
doing [ __ ] like he's got his own coin
yeah he's got some uh i think it's a
bitcoin or something that i don't know
he's killing it for sure being in canada
like uh a lot of cool things going on in
canada shrooms are legal
uh
i just saw that they actually just like
said something yesterday about they like
made it
legal and like more legal or something
out here no in canada oh i heard that
you could just rooms are just legal out
there maybe i'm wrong psilocybin is
maybe it is open opened up out there so
i don't know i'm american now man you
know you're american
is it kind of weird like uh being being
from canada and like seeing like uh
just how divisive and crazy america has
been
since you've been here yeah america is
pretty crazy it's just like canada's
crazy too though well yeah they got like
the truck [ __ ] going on their own they
got so much [ __ ] going on over there too
it's like man canada is [ __ ] crazy
too in its own way yeah i was just
[ __ ] cool at least you guys get free
health care
yeah i don't get it no more because i
was bad so if you break your leg you
don't go back home and just
nah nah you just gotta hang out i spend
too much time over here so it's like so
they're like [ __ ] you you're american
now yeah they're like [ __ ] wow that's
some [ __ ] they you should just be
canadian for life some [ __ ] [ __ ]
man shout out to canada it's crazy
though so like when i first started
coming to america and i tell people like
we're from canada like blah blah people
didn't give a [ __ ] but then when drake
started calling it the six and all that
movement started happening people oh
wait y'all from the six it was like
different then people were like [ __ ]
with us extra heavy just because we're
canadian you know what i mean
now canada has something in the water in
canada the last 10 years this is just
y'all ran music it's like justin
bieber's weekend you artists drake
goosers songwriters
no it's crazy and you know what's
another cool thing about canada is it's
almost like a bunch of like countries
within one country because there's like
parts of canada where everyone speaks
french like montreal and all that [ __ ]
there's parts that are like always snow
and like no one can live on they're like
those igloos and [ __ ] and then there's
like vancouver and just nardwar's there
interviewing everybody and yes star wars
have you done the nardwar interview i
need my interview yo nardwar sweetest
guy ever the ripest human being i've
ever met
i've met him four times and every time
i've been around nardwar
he's been extremely ripe that's crazy
yeah like
i'm like you know what he smells like i
how i thought he would smell that would
be fair that's cool yeah he did not
disappoint you know when you meet like a
famous person and they disappoint you
yeah narwhal did not disappoint that
happens a lot it does it does man it's
because you listen to people's music and
you think you know the patient yeah
there it is man well listen i appreciate
you pulling up appreciation uh one shot
go run it up the video's out yes sir uh
new music coming soon yes sir come on
man go tap in man murder beats boom